the foremost reason that happiness is so
hard to achieve is that the universe was
not designed with a comfort of human
beings in mind that's actually one of
the most powerful truths I have ever
encountered
we're drawn a chirally to comfort it
seems that for humans comfort is the
quintessential state but the universe
has a strange sense of humor it feels
like it played on us a cosmic joke were
the most desirable state can also be the
most destructive comfort feels good but
comfort is also transient perennial
immersion in one's comfort zone is
against the very nature of our existence
every time we make ourselves comfortable
we also find ourselves facing new
obstacles and challenges in other words
comfort is not efficacious so we
embarked on an arduous quest where we
had to overcome the limitations of our
cerebral and physical makeup and
confront any struggle that comes our way
and that's how we discovered flow flow
is something unnatural it's not the
state that you can generate on demand it
requires focus discipline and an astute
ability to shut down the cacophonous
mumbling of your ego nonetheless it
constitutes a strong remedy against
everything that limits our potential and
then endeavor from our side to showcase
the essence of what we're really made of
I remember the first time I entered flow
quite vividly I was in a nightclub
trying to maneuver myself through the
complex mechanics of our social
playgrounds I usually felt stifled in
such environments but not that night
that night I started with simple
interactions and once I felt enamored
with the environment
I started exhibiting bolder and bolder
moves I felt like there was no
resistance in my ability to showcase
social prowess and that I could interact
with anyone anywhere my mind was clear
there was no inner judgment and every
interaction evolved naturally at the end
of the night I felt serene I felt full I
felt elated
according to Mihai Csikszentmihalyi
flow is so powerful that it can actually
lead to accessing the
accessing classical Greek literature
refers to the removal of the minor body
from its normal place of function now
ecstasy in Greek meant simply to stand
to the side of something and then it
became essentially an analogy for a
mental state where you feel that you are
not doing your ordinary everyday
routines so ecstasy is essentially a
stepping into an alternative reality
with flow you feel as if you don't even
exist existence is temporarily suspended
brain imaging shows that when in flow
States we actually switch off the part
of the brain that gives us our sense of
self and the part that regulates our
brain function this part is called
dorsal lateral frontal cortex it is the
part of our brain that allows us to
analyze and question our own behavior
which can be highly useful unfortunately
it also slows everything down because it
means that all our decisions have to go
through it and it can act as a creative
barrier by switching off this part we
allow all our attention to go to the
part we want to use without censorship
or micromanagement these results in
quick reactions and uninterrupted
productivity
technically speaking flow is the sweet
spot between anxiety and boredom too
much anxiety can be crippling too much
boredom can be demoralizing flow acts as
the catalyst for finding a balance
between the two and reaching the optimal
state of man think of flow as a
conversion of your inner potentials into
pure kinetic energy as water flowing
seamlessly through a canal breaking down
the elements of flow can be confusing I
will attempt to do so nonetheless the
first and most important characteristic
of flow is having an achievable
objective this provides focus of energy
as well as movement of flow around and
over obstacles without an objective flow
would be dispersed an objective
shouldn't be something complicated you
just need to know your aim and have that
aim clearly identified in your head it's
important to know that having an
objective is different than being
outcome dependent an objective gives you
intent it doesn't feed your obsessions
being outcome dependent usually inhibits
flow because it strengthens the morning
of the ego creativity cannot thrive in
that space because it constantly
encounters ego barriers that question
its existence a clear objective is just
a composite allows creativity to
discover the path where it can prosper
this gives your actions the necessary
gravity required in order to discover
alternate paths
whenever you struggle with resistance an
objective is tantamount to a purpose The
Purpose Driven person will always master
willpower
whenever resistance tries to jeopardize
his or her actions
the word autotelic describes actions and
intentions that are self fulfilling
rather than means to an end while having
an objective is important the drive to
reach that objective is also important
this drive cannot be impulsive it needs
to feed on an energy source that is self
generating a drive to perform a set of
actions simply for the enjoyment of
doing them and caps relates the essence
of autotelic in an autotelic state you
become maximally engaged in the process
of producing the best outcome that you
can rather than simply going through the
motion hoping for some outcome
engagement needs to depth and Richard
Fineman used to say that everything is
interesting if you go into it deeply
enough we're usually obsessed with
rewards and the completion of stages
within the games that we decide to play
we forget that the process itself
oftentimes is more rewarding than the
price we desire and autotelic intention
is capable of generating positive
emotion which can be manifested into
internal drive the self rewarding
process isn't just central for the flow
mechanism but it also reveals its
miraculous nature
as you gain experience in doing
something your audacity intensifies and
gives rise to self-efficacy
self-efficacy reflects confidence in
your ability to exert control over your
own motivation behavior and environment
it is the ability to generate a mind map
that connects all the constituents of
your intended strategy the mind map
comes from both experience and the
intensity of your concentration on the
task at hand you know that the more you
focus on something the more power you
have to make it happen regardless the
obstacles you encounter this
self-efficacy gives cadence to your
actions you master a sense of timing and
momentum your path is charted out in
your mind and you discover that places
that seem so alien and arcane now seem
more familiar than ever flowing also
requires that we're attune to reality
into the prioritization of information
during flow State were working faster
than time itself and we are able to
process information in an intelligent
way people in flow seem to always be
able to distinguish the most relevant
information of the moment and create
opportunities from it this high
attunement to external events evolves
into higher and higher special awareness
that permeates the fabric of our
operational systems it is the
development of the fingers pits and give
fuel or the fingertip feel of our
environment we learn to trust our
intuition more than our judgment in
order to fill certain energies instead
of trying to analyze every action like a
hand reaching out that's the future we
are one step ahead unusually and the
vacuum of time becomes a playground of
now
in new environments the brain creates a
persona for you to present to the world
however during flow state your ego is
temporarily suspended your objective and
the emotions you someone seem to
outweigh the importance of persona and
Ingo you feel Auntie fragile and your
vision broadens beyond the narrow scope
of your usual interpretation of the
world and flow your brain is in
discovery mode you're living for the
sublime instead of looking for ways to
fit into conventions and justify
limiting beliefs with this discovery
comes a special knowledge of the danger
around you a willingness to be shut down
means that your brain can no longer
interpret rejection or fear as dangers
to avoid the ego is oppressed to make
way for the self to express itself fully
in this mindset you actually accept
rejection and fear as ordinary tenets of
life and incorporate them into your
overall flow the key to making this
process more seamless is to face the
most challenging aspects of your
objective head-on be willing to get
rejected be willing to battle with
resistance be willing to create
something simple that will evolve into
something more complicated in this model
your brain adapts and is no longer
intimidated by your limiting perceptions
the moment your ego is suspended your
brain will translate any feeling of
anxiety to a need for more audacity and
creativity the actual reason we discuss
flow is that it can really make you
happier happiness is not easy to define
but some of its constituents are ecstasy
and the ability to disengage from
self-destructive thoughts and behavioral
patterns flow is a state that has been
part of the human tapestry since the
time we were just trying to satisfy our
more primordial needs today it affects
every step of our attempt to achieve
self transcendence I would go as far as
to say that the theme of flow is an
attempt from the modern human to regain
his or her soul and overcome the
contemporary malaise of spiritual
stagnation hey guys hope you enjoyed
this video if you did make sure to LIKE
subscribe turn on notifications and
comment below something cool please so
that more
people can discover it if you want to
watch more videos from my channel check
out this one and this one take care see
you soon adrián out
[Music]